on a normal day Jose viator's restaurant
looks out onto one of martinique's
pristine white beaches
on a normal day his business is thriving
and the air doesn't smell like rotten
eggs
sargassum is the hardest challenge for
us every year we were forced to close
our business because of the gas there's
just no way we can serve customers under
these conditions
it started in 2011 millions of tons of
the free-floating brown seaweed called
sargassum stretching for thousands of
kilometers in the Atlantic Ocean enters
the Caribbean
it chokes coves and blankets beaches and
as it rots it releases toxic gases like
ammonia and hydrogen sulfide
people complain of sore throats nausea
and headaches and it's happening close
to the peak of the tourism season and is
having a devastating effect on the
economy
before it was very busy but now with the
seaweed there's no one left tourists say
they can't stay here maybe because of
their health or the smell I don't know
but we can't get by without them
fishermen are doing what they can using
booms and Nets and adapting their boats
to trap hundreds of cubic meters of the
algae every hour
if it doesn't reach Shore and is
collected in a net it won't rot and
release hydrogen sulfide so we think
it's one of the best Solutions that's
why we're building other boats with new
technologies to go even faster because
we realize that when there are large
quantities of the seaweed we have to
move quickly to collectors
sargassum blooms Every Spring in the
Atlantic but in the past decade it's
been flourishing breaking records nearly
every year scientists think ocean
warming and Industrial runoff could be
to blame
the forecasts are not very good
scientifically I don't know what to do
humanly speaking we are finding
Solutions and I think we will also reach
a point where we will be able to use it
as raw material for something
NASA has already warned that 2023 is
the largest bloom
Bloomville of Martinique will be on the
front lines and hope the solutions
they're developing will go some way to
helping the rest of the Caribbean
Alexandra Byers Al Jazeera